[Applause]
it was a packed house in the Rod Laver
Arena nearly 15 000 fans turning out to
see Elena Rebecca against Arena
zabalenka two Gladiators competing for
the first grand slam of the year
it was Rebecca who started strongest
kazakhstan's star looking for her second
major title in seven months after
winning Wimbledon last year she took the
opening set six games to four
it was the first set sabalenka had
dropped in 2023 but she began to settle
down in what was her first major final
the fifth seed had won her previous
three meetings with Rebecca and she took
the second set 6-3 to square things up
[Applause]
that effectively set up a one-set
shootout for the trophy and the momentum
stayed with zabalenka
she got the crucial break and soon found
herself serving for the match
she failed to convert three Championship
points but at the fourth time of asking
she finally got over the line
it's the first Grand Slam title for the
24 year old because of belarus's support
of the Russian invasion of Ukraine she
wasn't allowed to officially represent
her country in Melbourne meaning she's
the first ever neutral player to win a
tennis Grand Slam
it's the first tennis major to offer
equal prize money to the men and women
so as well as the trophy zabalenka takes
home around 2 million dollars
[Applause]
thank you guys for an amazing atmosphere
I hope next year I come I come back
stronger and I'll show you even better
tennis and you guys support me even more
[Applause]
zabalanka's 11th straight win of the
Year Caesar returned to a career high
world number two ranking David Stokes Al
Jazeera